on the hill tonight for the giants will
be
that gentleman right there logan webb
the 23-year-old right-hander out of
rocklin california first time he's ever
faced seattle j.p crawford stands in
blowing outside for ball
four so jp with the lead-off walk here
in the top of the first inning there's
second baseman dylan moore
inside and that hits dylan in the back
more hit by a pitch from logan webb
gets on the hard way so two on right
away for the mariners with nobody out
here in the top of the first and that'll
bring up center fielder kyle lewis
tapped to webb he juggles it he better
hurry and they got him well we'll be
upset because he was going to go to
third but he couldn't get a handle on it
one out and two on its going position
and here is third baseman kyle seeger
back up the middle
they have played perfectly crawford's
there over to belt for the outrun scores
mariners have a one-nothing lead
so now two down and the mariners have a
run without a hit so here's ty franz
and he strikes him out swinging with a
high fastball and the inning is over
rookie right-hander lj newsom getting
his third appearance and second start of
the year he is a strike throwing machine
leading things off mike yastrimsky for
the giants
swaying animus for strike three so right
away
lj newsom with his first strikeout of
the night he fans mike istremski
alex dickerson sends one deep in front
of 365.
marmo there to make the catch two down
that will bring up second baseman
donovan solano solano having a great
year for san francisco he's adding third
in the national league getting 3
41. swing there's a shot into the gap at
right center field that's going to split
the defense
it's going to roll all the way out to
the 415 marker and solano winds up on a
third with a two out triple
and here is first baseman brandon belt
and now the giants have the time run 90
feet away
he dumps one into right field and he's
got a base hit
and this game is tied the mariners have
the bases loaded with one out here on
the top of any number two and here
is jp crawford line drive down the left
field line this one is going to be a
fair ball all the way to the wall into
the corner
jp will clear the bases throw to third
and crawford is out at third base
but the meredith pick up a three spot
right there on the double by j.p
crawford shortstop brandon crawford
leading off the bottom of the second
oh that is off of lj looks like off his
hand his pitching hand that's not good
couldn't defend himself oh that's a
shame that's a shame he had a 4-1
lead and he's got to take his leave here
four to one mariners
as we start the third inning that brings
up ty france
d-8 tonight so i mean this is lace
towards right field over towards the
alley and
the catch is not made by yastrimsky
yassrinsky rolls all the way to the base
of the wall
ty france stands up at third base with a
triple and i wonder if that one got
caught in the lights
as sure handed as you strip that's the
only way you could explain that he never
saw it i don't think he did
so runner at third one out for
marmalajos swinging it's pulled into
right field for a base hit
this brings home france from third base
the mariners had sported each of the
first three innings tonight
five to one mariners two down with alex
dickerson coming up dickerson might have
just missed a home run
in the first inning dickerson blasts one
to deep right field he didn't miss this
one
it is on its way and it is gone and a
fan out there saves it from bouncing
into san francisco bay
dickerson gets the giants a little bit
closer it's
five to two the giants offense starting
to get revved up again
a two out double donovan solano's two
for two with a triple and a double
we'll see if belt can drive in solana
for the second time already
belt base hit right where the
shortstop's supposed to be
here comes solano and it's 5-3
mariners leading the giants five to
three leading things off brandon
crawford swinging a chopper to the right
side of the infield cutting it crosses
crawford the shortstop dives shovels the
ball over to white
in time for the out on brandon crawford
what a play by
j.p crawford again brandon never made
the transfer just shoveled it
right on the money to evan white what a
play by j.p
crawford so bart is aboard for mauricio
dubois and the wind is blowing out
hit high and deep down the left field
line toward the corner
long is going back he's at the wall it
is gone
mauricio duvan hit a towering home run
it was like it was never going to come
down it's
five to five so two outs now and it's up
to jp crawford to try to cash in on this
white at third terrence at second swung
on there's a drive in a deep left center
field
that is well struck but back near the
warning track goes dickerson and he
makes the catch
and the inning is over so the mariners
were the threat they had second and
third and one out but they do not score
now the mariners are cooking in a tie
game with two on two out the left-hander
marmalejos
comes up marmalayos grounds one softly
up the middle crawford is there
has it from behind the bag at second
throws to first for the out
and the mariners are retired one out
base is empty you got alex dickerson due
up next but the giants are going to use
ruff's had a lot of big hits lately for
the giants that one is blasted to left
field
going back on it is long at the wall
it's gone as a pinch hitter darren
ruff has gone deep and put the giants
ahead
six to five arlene garcia the lefty to
the right-handed hitting evan white
here's the pitch
another slider strike on the inside
corner again
and somebody's just been thrown out of
the ball game so scott service has been
ejected by the home plate umpire lance
barrett
he's going to have a few words a little
closer
he did not like either slider to evan
white he thought both were down and in
the mariners have the time to run aboard
here in the top of the ninth inning and
that
will bring up kyle seeger and he rolls
this one to solano
and solano to belt and that's the ball
here
so the giants snap to mariners six-game
winning streak